today on the matt walsh show rabid mobs
continue to wreak havoc and destruction
in wisconsin and elsewhere across the
country all with the explicit support of
course of the democrat party nancy
pelosi
said yesterday that republicans are
domestic enemies but that label applies
much more to democrats also five
headlines including jerry falwell jr in
a throuple
allegedly incredibly important story
here that we'll talk about and in our
daily cancellation i will cancel phds
all phds
are are canceled and i'll explain why
but first
let me tell you about charity mobile new
sponsors on the show that i'm very
excited about
charity mobile is the pro-life phone
company and they really earn that label
listen to this 5 of your monthly plan
price goes to the pro-life pro family
charity of your choice
so you get to decide which means uh you
get a great service and you're also
performing an active charity at the same
time
and i should emphasize that it is a
great service i use it myself
i couldn't be happier with it new
activations and eligible accounts get a
free cell phone with free activation and
free shipping
so there are all kinds of additional
perks that come with this and
you know you could take those perks
while feeling good because you're
helping a worthy cause at the same time
the most worthy cause of course is the
pro-life cause because if we aren't
defending life
the dignity of life in this country if
we don't start with that premise then
there's nowhere else to go from there by
the way no contracts no termination fees
and no risk there's a 30-day guarantee
and if you have any issues any problems
well they've got live customer service
based in the usa to help you out
so uh they're gonna you know they're
there for you as well to help you here's
what it comes down to for me you know i
can turn
everyday living into effortless giving
for the charity of my choice
best of all worlds classic win-win
situation so here's what you need to
need to do call charity mobile at
1-877-474-3662 or chat with us online
at charitymobile.com that's
charitymobile.com
okay so last night was another night
of violence and anarchy in kenosha
wisconsin as riders continue to fight
for human rights tolerance and equality
through random destruction as is their
uh
general mo you already know you know
what what this looks like of course
because it's what black lives matter has
been doing all over the country for
months now or really years but
i want to play a few of the clips
because i think it's important that we
that people see this and keep seeing it
for as long as it happens so first
here are the freedom fighters walking
down a line of cars
and vandalizing them one by one
[Music]
and here we have a furniture store set
on fire in the name of justice of course
[Music]
and then again uh you know this is all
for justice and peace just want to
emphasize want you to understand justice
and peace
here's a truck set on fire
and then you can see other buildings uh
set on fire as well
hey
oh and i think this is interesting um
this particular group of freedom
fighters they really seem to have
something against street lamps that
they're knocking down all over the place
like you see right here
wow
and you know street lamps perpetuate
systemic racism
somehow so it makes sense now all of
this obviously was ostensibly sparked by
the shooting of jacob blake
who as we discussed yesterday was a
fugitive
wanted for domestic assault and sexual
assault with a history of resisting
arrest and pulling guns
he was shot while cops tried to arrest
him because he went to his car open the
door and reached inside
we still haven't been told you know
whether he had a gut in his car or not
there's a lot of unanswered questions
though it doesn't really matter that
much at the end of the day because
he gave cops very good reason to think
he was reaching for a gun whether he had
one or not
and if he wasn't reaching for a gun then
his actions become completely impossible
to understand
not that reaching for a gun is
understandable either but then if there
was nothing there what was he doing and
it would seem almost to be like a
suicide-by-cop situation
i'm not saying that was the case but i
can't imagine why else you would behave
that way
in that situation and while we're on the
subject a new angle
of the altercation is now making the
rounds it's difficult to see what's
happening here exactly except that you
can tell
that blake is definitely fighting the
cops take a look
[Applause]
so like i said hard to decipher the
specifics but this confirms for sure
that he was resisting and brawling with
the cops
and then he went to his car while they
had guns pointed at him
um there are you know different
perspectives you can have on this case
and no matter your perspective there's
still a lot we don't know we don't know
if blake had a gun in the car we don't
know if he was being arrested because of
his warrants which would mean the cops
knew that he had a history of resisting
arrest and pulling guns on cobbs
um that's very important to know and we
don't know that we don't know many
things
but whatever your take on this no honest
person can claim
that this is some kind of racist
execution there's no reason to
think that yet that is precisely what's
being claimed by the rioters and by
democrats at the highest levels of the
party
we already talked about the governor of
wisconsin yesterday how he immediately
without any information
tied this to racism and said essentially
that it was a merciless execution
even though uh even though jacob blake
is is still alive the biting campaign
for its part put out a statement
yesterday
here's what it says um yesterday in
kenosha wisconsin jacob blake was shot
seven times in the bag as police
attempted to restrain him from getting
into his car
his children watched from inside uh the
car and bystanders watched in disbelief
and this morning the nation wakes up yet
again with grief and outrage that yet
another black victim is a victim a black
black american is a victim of excessive
force this calls for immediate full and
transparent investigation
and the officers must be held
accountable notice how he calls for
an investigation only after passing a
verdict
that it was excessive force force so he
says
here's what happened i've decided now we
need an investigation to confirm
what i just said this is how democrats
operate they pass the verdict
and then investigate to find evidence to
support the verdict they already passed
if no such evidence is found they either
disregard the evidence and continue
along with their verdict anyway their
narrative
or they toss their narrative aside and
pretend it never happened
um but biden continues he says
these shots pierce the soul of our
nation equal justice has not been real
for black americans and so many others
we are we are at an inflection point we
must dismantle systemic racism
it is the urgent task before us we must
fight to honor the ideals laid in the
original american promise
which we are yet to attain that all men
and women are created equal but more
importantly
that they must be treated equally
all of this everything you just heard
is at the very best highly irresponsible
and reckless at worst
it is intentional you know it
intentionally encourages
more rioting and destruction by propping
up a false narrative that has nothing at
all to do with this case
and usually when it comes to democrats
the at worst option is correct
which brings me finally after a long
setup to the words of nancy pelosi many
conservatives yesterday were upset by
what she had to say on msnbc about her
political opponents
um but i'm not very upset by it uh and
i'll tell you why but first
listen to this we take an oath to
protect and defend the constitution from
all enemies
foreign and domestic and sadly the
domestic
enemies to our voting system and our
honoring our constitution
are right at 1600 pennsylvania avenue
with their allies in the congress of the
united states
but again let's just get out there and
mobilize organize and not
let the president deter anybody uh from
voting and again
support the postal system which is
elections
election central they're doing
everything they can suppress
the vote of with your actions
scare people intimidate by saying law
enforcement will be there
uh diminish the role of the
of the postal system in all of this it's
really actually shameful
enemies of the state domestic enemies
enemies of the state that's what nancy
pelosi calls republicans
some republicans were scandalized by
this oh the rhetoric
what rude such mean the rhetoric is so
hurtful to our feelings the rhetoric
well get over it you whimpering sissies
stop stop scolding them for being mean
to you and throw it right back at them
because in fact
this is exactly how i feel about the
democrat party
and in this case it's true the democrat
party is a domestic enemy
enemies of the state this is a party
that is actively fueling encouraging
promoting
calling for violence and destruction in
our streets
many hundreds of millions of dollars
have been lost from the damage wrought
by the crazed mobs that democrats
support
many dozens of people have been killed
and this is what they want this is the
rallying cry
more unrest in the street is what
representative ayanna presley asked for
last week
she's comfortable she's safe she's
privileged but she doesn't care if your
house burns
your business your livelihood if you're
assaulted or killed by a rabid mob of
racial avengers
she doesn't care you're a political pawn
to her nothing more
your life has no meaning to her and the
same is true of everyone else leading
this corrupt party of hustlers and liars
this is way beyond democrats merely
refusing to condemn the violence of
course they have refused to condemn it
four nights at the convention last week
and
not once did anyone breathe a word of
criticism towards antifa or blm
just like they didn't condemn the blm
activists who beat a man unconscious
they aren't condemning anything that's
happened in wisconsin or anywhere else
we know that
but it's a lot worse than that it goes
way beyond a failure to condemn it goes
way beyond
silence they provide cover for the
violence
thus facilitating it they want our
cities to burn
they want racial strife they want a race
war
they want black people to believe
falsely that they are being hunted in
the street by racist cops
they want paranoia they want fear they
want hatred resentment vengeance
this is a political party without a soul
without a hint of any redeeming quality
whatsoever
without a shred of integrity or decency
and i don't say any of this as a way of
propping up republicans the republican
party is useless and cowardly as far as
i'm concerned but
the democrat party is morally deranged
to a degree that we have not seen in
american politics
in a very long time it is an active
threat to our system of government
our way of life our civilization i'm
sorry if this rhetoric is disturbing to
you
i'm sorry if it makes your tummy hurt a
little when you hear it but it's the
truth
and we have to start with square one
here which is recognizing
and facing the truth whatever it means
and wherever it leads let's go to five
headlines
[Music]
before we get into five headlines let me
tell you about ziprecruiter uh
one of my favorite sponsors on the show
you know hiring is challenging
especially with everything else you got
going on these days
uh you know it's it's a difficult time
to run a business but
there's one place where you can go where
hiring is simple fast and smart and a
place where businesses can connect
qualified candidates you get all that in
one place the place is ziprecruiter.com
walsh ziprecruiter what they're gonna do
is they're gonna send your job to over
a hundred of the web's leading job sites
but they don't stop there okay so it's
not just like they're sending it out
into the void and
waiting for something to happen with
their powerful matching technology zip
recruiter
scans thousands of resumes to find
people with the right experience
and then actively invites them to apply
for your job so there's an active
solicitation here going on
for job candidates zip recruiters so
effective that four out of five
employers who post onset recruiter
get a quality candidate within the first
day
uh you can't ask you really you
literally can't ask for for better
results than that
and uh let's let's make it even better
right now to try zip recruiter for free
my listeners can go to
ziprecruiter.comwalls.ziprecruiter.com
walsh walsh ziprecruiter.com
walsh zip recruiter the smartest way to
hire
okay the rnc happened last night as you
might expect uh i didn't watch but
based on the highlights after the fact i
say that
the best moment um wasn't any address
given by any politician but
instead the short remarks from the
mccloskeys now that's the married couple
that
stood outside their homes to defend it
against
a mob that was descending on their
neighborhood is now being prosecuted
for that entirely legal uh act an act
protected by the second amendment and
they were invited to
deliver a message and i thought it was
short and to the point and pretty
powerful listen
america is such a great country that not
only do you have the right to own a gun
and use it to defend yourself but
thousands of americans will offer you
free advice
on how to use it at least that's what we
experienced
what you saw happen to us could just as
easily happen to any of you
who are watching from quiet
neighborhoods around our country
and that's what we want to speak to you
about tonight
that's exactly right whether it's the
defunding of police
ending cash bails or criminals can be
released back out on the streets the
same day
to riot again or encouraging anarchy and
chaos on our streets
it seems as if the democrats no longer
view the government's job
as protecting honest citizens from
criminals
but rather protecting criminals from
honest citizens
not a single person in the out of
control mob you saw at our house
was charged with a crime but you know
who was
we were and those are exactly the kinds
of messages that the republican party i
think needs to amplify
and so far at their convention they are
which is great it wasn't all smooth
sailing though it seems that a few of
the speakers forgot
that there was no audience and which
which is tough okay it's like it's
especially if you don't do any public
speaking you might not it might not be
entirely obvious
why it's uh so difficult why this is
like an extra challenge of not having an
audience when you're giving a speech
because you just have to calibrate
things differently it's an entirely
different
you know environment when you don't have
an audience to play off of you don't
have the you know applause
and everything so i think some of the
speakers forgot that
and um went for the screaming raucous
pep rally speech in spite of the fact
that there was no screaming raucous
pep rally audience there kimberly
guilfoyle
um for example turned the dial up to 11
for her speech which normally i'm all in
favor of
but it didn't quite work given the
crickets in the background watch
watch a clip of this ladies and
gentlemen
leaders and fighters for freedom and
liberty and the american dream
the best is yet to come
that's that's rough that's uh that's
pretty hilarious actually in a really
uncomfortable
the office sort of way in fact it
reminds me of that scene i don't know if
you're if you're an office fan you know
you must have thought immediately the
same thing i did which is the swing the
scene of dwight
at the salesman convention getting his
award uh
really there's major vibes of of that
going on
um but the effect is it's it's really
it's like if you went back
watching a speech without an audience
it's it's like if you went back and
watched an episode of
like king of queens without the laugh
track
so it's you know a scene where kevin
james gets caught
uh eating from the jar of mayonnaise or
whatever and then his wife berates him
and verbally abuses him for three
minutes
a scene like that without the cue of the
crowd
laughing would be like depressing
and disturbing and it would make you
want to call
the police about about the domestic
abuse
but with the crowd telling you this is
funny laugh it has a whole different
flavor to it so
same here with the convention speeches
you don't realize how important the
psychological cues
of the crowd are until you don't have it
so we are sheep is what i'm trying to
tell you we react
to things emotionally based on how other
people are reacting
they tell us how we're supposed to react
and then we react that way okay
number two a guy named giancarlo grande
says that he has been in a throuple sort
of with jerry falwell jr and his wife
for many years now
he's also a business partner of fall
wells to make things weirder
and to make them even weirder from what
i understand
uh the business partnership started
after
the throuple business not that it would
be much better if it was before but i
don't know it's just weird like
you're in a this kind of arrangement and
and then
you decide to start a business together
um so he says the couple met him
when he was a pool boy and it's really
actually a pool boy and then he soon
started a relationship with falwell's
wife
and then and then falwell uh
will watch uh you know as they're
involved
in in in their activities as he's
involved in an activity
when i say in an activity i don't mean
playing monopoly okay you get my drift
but uh he's involved in in that with the
wife and then falwell will watch
uh so falwell's literal cuckhold if this
is true now
the board of directors at liberty have
asked falwell to resign
uh he originally said he was going to
and then he said he wasn't and but now
from what i understand he really is
resigning and this is all coming on the
heels of of of
of that picture of him with his pants
unbuttoned
on the yacht with the young woman and
then and then if you recall he called
into a radio show to explain it and he
really
seemed to be drunk or out of it in some
way when he was on the radio show
so it's been one humiliating episode
after another and normally i would say
that this is salacious gossip it's
irrelevant
uh who cares and that's still how i feel
like
i don't care that much but the problem
here is that falwell
is was a powerful
christian leader quote-unquote christian
leader um big scare quotes on that
and he made millions of dollars by
cultivating that brand
and selling it to the public and
convincing you know people to send
their kids to his school a school where
by the way
many kids have been expelled for doing
exactly the kinds of things that he was
apparently doing
all the time in his private life if you
do that
and then it turns out that you're a
degenerate weirdo well then
your degeneracy is news and and that's
really your fault i don't feel at all
sorry for you
you you you profited off of cultivating
a brand that was completely false and
you treated your faith like a brand
made a lot of money off of it and now
you're exposed that's your fault
and personally i'm i'm so damn tired
of quote unquote christian leaders
turning out to be scumbags that i just
i have no sympathy for them no appetite
to defend them not that i would defend
them anyway but i you know just
uh you want to mock them and laugh with
them go ahead really
they deserve it i'm so tired of this i'm
not surprised by it
that's sort of my point i wish i was
surprised i wish i was surprised that
someone like jerry falwell jr
is this not at all none of us are it's
what we come to expect
and it really shouldn't be that way
all right let's go to number three
here's an interesting video it appears
that black lives matter scumbags were
marching through dc i think it was it's
the claim online is that it's d i'm not
sure what city this is but
they were apparently demanding that
people at uh the restaurant you're about
to see here
raise their fists for black power and
one brave couple refuses to act like a
trained seal
responding to commands and this is what
happened because of that
[Music]
huh
yes be that couple that's the couple you
should be those are brave people who
retain their dignity
now personally i would have loved to see
them raise the fist
and then slowly turn it around and raise
the middle finger you know
i i would have that would have been fun
if they had done that
but this was good too so be them
do not be the embarrassing mustachioed
coward to the right who you probably
noticed
uh with sitting there with his fist up
you know and just that look of
total shame on his face
how do you live with yourself after that
you've got this mob
of of scumbags just shouting at you
telling you to to bark on command like a
dog
and you actually do it
and it's on film i mean how do you live
with that
totally embarrassing he's given up his
dignity forever and it's it's really not
worth it
so good for that couple and that's how
everybody should respond
i mean it really doesn't matter it
doesn't matter what they tell you to do
you gotta this this this
you know mob of bullies coming back hey
do this
dude perform this act right now because
i told you to
i don't care what it is you should
refuse to do it
on the principle of it oh well who do
you think you are i'm not going to
listen to you why
why should i listen to you why why
i don't care at all what your opinion is
of me
all right very important report here
from the new york post uh it says while
older texters may consider the the
period
uh in an innocent symbol that a sentence
has ended digital natives consider it a
triggering form of aggression
the punctuation problem ignited over
social media recently with gen z and
millennials agreeing that
ending a sentence with a period is
overly hostile
and worse yet extremely uncool um
digital culture journalist victoria turk
in her book
kill reply all it's a book on digital
etiquette so you go pick that up
said only old people or troubled souls
put periods at the end of every sentence
the younger generations consider the act
of sending a text a sufficient
signifier of a complete thought turk
wrote making periods feel unnecessary
and overly final um okay
and it's a long it goes on from there we
could keep reading but i won't
i just have to say you know i could just
sum it up i'm actually in full agreement
with this um and i thought this was
common
knowledge that periods
in a in a paragraph or a series of
sentences
are fine of course very much advised in
that case
but a period after one word or one
sentence and then
sent via text messages or message or
email is passive-aggressive
um and this is simply a fact
i thought everyone knew that and since
we're canceling punctuation marks i
would also like to throw in
speaking of aggressive punctuation marks
the exclamation point
i think also deserves to be on the ash
sheep of history exclamation points are
almost never necessary if you want to
communicate
enthusiasm you're excited about
something you should be able to do
that via the words you're typing you
should be able to express yourself
in a way that makes your enthusiasm
clear without needing the exclamation
point
and this is especially true of men
okay it's women can get away with
exclamation points
children can get away with excellent if
you're a grown man you should never be
using an exclamation point
except sarcastically or ironically those
are pretty much the only times where
it's acceptable
speaking of dignity no grown man can
keep his dignity
while sending an exclamation point and
that is also just a simple fact
five finally another thing um here that
gets my full endorsement in agreement
report from sky news that says kiev's
kfc will
suspend its finger licking good slogan
after 64 years
because it doesn't quite fit with
coronavirus hygiene messaging
the u.s fried chicken chain has released
new images of advertising posters and
packaging
with the slogan blurred and pixelated
it says colonel sanders is uh it's
finger licking good saying will return
when the time is right
but we'll alter its messaging for now uh
because they're you know they're worried
about the the chronovirus
this is good and responsible i'm i'm on
board with it and it has nothing to do
with coronavirus for me just in general
people who lick their fingers after
eating
are disgusting savages unfit for human
society
it may in fact be the number one most
nauseating personal habit a person can
possibly have
it's it's barbaric and the worst thing
is
how many people after licking their
fingers
actually go and wash their hands their
fingers are now
covered in their own slobber how many of
those people are going to wash their
hands
very few of them because they think
their saliva is sufficient they're like
cats thinking they can clean themselves
with their own tongues
i hate to see how they clean the rest of
their bodies i don't know if they're
like in the shower with the shower
turned off spitting on themselves
washing in the mucus with a with a
loofah i i don't know
but this just to be clear we are human
beings our saliva is not sterile
okay there's all kinds of germs in it
it's completely disgusting
we have invented you know we live in a
civilized world we have running water in
faucets
wherever you are there's probably one
nearby even if you don't have access to
a faucet
there's still no excuse to lick your
fingers
so i'm i'm uh this has been my
i've been boycotting kfc really for for
years just because of this slogan i
think it's the most offensive slogan
from from any company and i'm glad
they're finally getting rid of it
okay um now let's get to our
speaking of offensive we'll get to our
daily cancellation today for our daily
cancellation i'm cancelling phds
and i'll explain why this starts
recently a phd expert
scolded me on twitter for my objectional
opinions on gender and other related
topics you know i made the argument
as i made on the show that one of the
primary tools used to sexualize children
in our culture
is trans indoctrination and because of
that dr
logan levcov swooped in to expose and
annihilate my transphobia
with the scorching rays of her superior
education and intellect
she countered that quote the primary
tool in our culture used to create fear
and hate about gender identity is matt
walsh
which is a flattering claim by the way
that sadly i can't possibly live up to
though i wish i could
and she reminded the reader that i am
not an expert in gender or sexuality and
therefore
nobody should listen to me she is an
expert though or at least that's the
title she's given to herself
her bio on her website informs us that
she is a sex educator
a quote internationally recognized
expert on sexuality and relationships
and a quote thought leader in the field
of human sexuality
and personal relationships on top of all
that she was incredibly humble
now as an uneducated bumpkin myself with
only a high school diploma to my name
i sensed an opportunity here to be
educated so i sat down at my computer in
my tattered
dungarees with a piece of straw hanging
out of my mouth this is how she'd
probably imagine the scene anyway
and i asked the good the good doctor the
question that i've been posing
to proponents of left-wing gender theory
for years now
what is a woman that's my classic
question you've heard it from me many
times
i've not been able to extract a coherent
response from anyone on the left no
matter how often i try
but i figured that if anyone could rise
to the challenge
it would be a phd who is recognized
internationally
as an expert in the field of knowing
what gender is
so her first answer to the question was
kind of disappointing though she said
quote
gender is a social construct womanhood
or manhood is not defined by
reproductive organs or genitals
assigned sex at birth is also not a
binary and sexual orientation is not the
same as gender identity it's fairly
simple
and you're welcome now there are a lot
of problems here beginning with the fact
that she didn't define the word she
didn't answer the question
instead she offered up a whole bunch of
additional vague concepts that need
their own definitions
what does she mean by assigned sex who
is the sex assigner
god nature surely she must know that
doctors at the hospital don't assign sex
it's not as though they're pulling
babies out of the womb and randomly
attaching boy or girl genitals to them
like potato head dolls
doctors notice or observe the sex they
don't assign it
she also gives the classic gender as a
social construct canard now i call that
a classic but we should note that it's a
very new classic
prior to the arbitrary invention of
gender as a human
a human identity which is a concept
largely pioneered by the way by a a
pedophilic quack name
named john money who tried tried out
these theories on two young boys who
later went on to kill themselves but
that's a story that deserves more of a
focus
than i can give it right now prior to
any of that
gender was a grammatical category words
had gender people had sex
uh we are now told that people have both
sex and gender
but the people telling us that have
never quite been able to explain how the
two are different and why we need both
concepts
plus as i've argued many times the false
sex verse gender dichotomy contradicts
the trans narrative as invariably
it's a child's affinity to to the gender
constructs of the other sex
that is cited as a reason to transition
them to that sex in the first place but
if the constructs are artificial
then why assume that a child's
identifying with them has any deeper
meaning at all in other words
why can't he just be a feminine boy
you know feminine by society standards
boy are we not reinforcing the
constructs by insisting that feminine
boys are actually girls because only
girls can be feminine
this answer from our expert simply
doesn't work on any level unfortunately
um
so i you know i asked again and she
tried again a few minutes later
after consulting with her expert level
phd books
she said what is a woman anything she
wants to be
this is about the caliber of insight
that i might expect from a fortune
cookie
and they give you fortune cookies for
free with your order of kung pao chicken
i really hate to think how much dr logan
spent on university courses in order to
attain
a similar level of enlightenment so
that's kind of disturbing
needless to say anything she wants to be
cannot be a valid definition for the
word woman definitions are supposed to
tell you
what a thing is this definition tells me
almost nothing about women except that
apparently they're shape-shifters
which is an interesting fact no doubt
but i don't feel that i'm much closer to
understanding the concept of womanhood
fundamentally so uh you know i had to i
had to press further and and finally
our sex and gender expert made one more
attempt and offered this up as a
definition
she says i was giving you more info than
you asked for because you clearly didn't
know the difference between assigned sex
and birth and gender
obviously that was too complex for you a
woman is someone who
identifies as female female identity and
female assignment
may be different okay now we're getting
somewhere
or are we let's break this down a little
bit
a woman is someone who identifies as
female
let's try to understand this what is a
female well
female is someone with two x chromosomes
and a vagina and a uterus
okay what does identify as mean well
that can mean any number of things
identify could mean recognize or observe
you know we say that a witness may
identify the suspect meaning
hey that guy that's the guy i recognize
him
is this what identify as female means
women are people who recognize that they
have two
x chromosomes and that can't be it
because obviously males can't recognize
2x chromosomes within themselves because
they don't have them
and what about women who have them but
don't recognize them are they not women
so that doesn't work now dictionary.com
has another definition that might be
might help us a little bit more it says
it says
identify can also be a verb meaning to
associate oneself in feeling interest
action etc with a specified group or
belief system
okay now this seems to this seems to be
what we're talking about right
but a number of problems present
themselves first of all how can you
associate yourself
in feeling an interest with a certain
set of chromosomes
and even if you can is there not
obviously a difference between the group
that has the chromosomes
and the group that identifies with the
group that has it
it identifies as denotes anything that
it must by definition to note that there
is a difference between those who
have or those who are and those who
identify as and if there is no
difference then why
do we even need this identify as
business at all
why do we need the prefix trans so it
seems we're left with
women who are females by definition
and then this other group uh who are men
some of whom have some kind of hazy
ill-defined
vague affinity for some aspects of what
our culture considers feminine
now you can call that ladder group
whatever you want or whatever they want
except you cannot call them women
because women are precisely the group
they identify with
which means they are not in it but
outside it and identifying with it
so this definition doesn't work either
women cannot by definition
be both females and not females given
that male and female they're only two
options
if women are females or males then women
aren't anything in particular
and we're back to not having a
definition the good doctor after
hundreds of thousands of dollars spent
on our education and so many years as an
expert traveling the globe to deliver
her expertise and
and and educate everybody and and pass
on her wisdom
apparently still doesn't have an
understanding on the topic of gender
that rises even to the level of my
seven-year-old son and this is why we're
canceling phds
you're still allowed to get one if you
want i will permit it in my in my
generosity
but just know that getting a whole bunch
of certificates and calling yourself an
expert
doesn't make you one in fact in this
country today you can
be a certified expert in a field without
knowing the first damn thing about it
what we find is that for some people the
process of education is a process of
finding long and windy and tortured ways
around facts
and truth many of our experts are
experts at sounding smart
while being stupid in other words and
that's because
the process of learning won't amount to
actual knowledge if you're not
learning with the intent of pursuing
truth
much of the learning that goes on in our
country especially in the higher
institutions
is learning ways around truth not
ways to it and that's how you end up
with legions of experts who are
essentially
large grapefruits with wigs and faces
drawn on in sharpie
at least they are comparable to
grapefruits when it comes to their depth
of real knowledge and understanding
and so phds are cancelled the good
doctor is cancelled
and just for good measure i'm also going
to cancel everyone who calls themselves
a doctor when they're not medical
doctors because
come on you know we all know that's
pretty lame so stop that too
uh everyone there is cancelled and i
guess we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening have a great day godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more
see you there